all you can say about the two thousands
mm were the absolute worst decade at
least since the 1990s wad box fuzzy
Matlock bomb fuzzy mass OCH box
fuzzy Matlock box ah gee man the worst
thing about war V Bush was that one side
had to win brownie you're doing a heck
of a job god damn it Bush hadn't dodged
that well sin Vietnam Barney there's no
easy way to say this but we're out of
money I don't know what's more
disturbing that he's talking to a dog
like David Berkowitz or that he told
Barney two years before he told the rest
of us that we're out of money awesome
what newspapers and maggots
the sad thing is she might be smarter
than joepie humbly with a stock market
crash Franklin Roosevelt got on
television that's the most persistently
I've ever seen Reagan could do that with
his eyes reporting for duty no wonder we
lost Vietnam they didn't do anything
wrong I have nothing I'd like that guy's
hair I've been unfaithful to Allah I was
wrong I'm sorry I'm truly sorry please
let me apologize
I missed the nineties when our
politicians had sex in actual rooms will
you please stop dancing this is the clip
reel of the damned
he's always had a problem with exit
strategy we all remember Bobby Kennedy
was assassinated I've now been in 57
states why why aren't we questioning the
underlying premise of the need for a
bailout with taxpayers money anytime
dennis kucinich is the voice of reason
you know you're really screwed the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2009 is to be awarded to
President Barack Obama worst decade ever